It is argued,
tend to like younger women tend to like
particular figures like large hips
visits that are good for childbearing
and large breasts that are good for
breastfeeding.
Uh,
and women tend to like strong,
masculine,
big shouldered men who can take care of
their child and them.
Uh,
and there may be some truth to that kind
of thing.
I think that it's,
it's,
it's too neat of a system.
There are lots of popular books written
that way.
Lots of,
uh,
when I teach undergraduates,
they love those socio biological notions
because it's just a nice,
neat little system.
Uh,
but I think it's too neat.
I think that,
uh,
and it varies from culture to culture at
different points in our own culture.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
we've put on a pedestal more corpulent
women,
uh,
n and D and cultures.
For example,
the perfect body style for a woman a is
not the hourglass figure,
but more of a,
of a squat square figure.
Uh,
so it's,
it's,
it's too easy for us to extrapolate from
cultural,
current cultural norms and then say,
this is some sort of evolutionary
propensity.
Um,
there do seem to be more pairings of
older,
wealthy men and younger,
uh,
women,
which evolutionary theory would lead us
to believe.
But you also am always struck by a
newspaper reports of older women going
out with younger men.
And you see more and more of that these
days.
And that's,
that's not at all what evolution would,
would have his thing.